préparatifs de dernière minute pour les
animateurs des comptes jour yopi cette
semaine les conduire du québec
accueilleront leurs premiers campeurs
avec en trame de fond
lakovic 19 donc on n'a pas eu ça souffle
à pour que le premier temps puis d'aller
s'asseoir dans leur sceau de leur
remettre la chose individuel on va
traîner les cerceaux et on s'est dit ça
même si on voit à l'extérieur pour
manger la même chose raison du cerceau
bluff c'est un mètre de distance chez
pas de problème on était synonyme
d'adaptation selon l'association des
camps du québec
l'offre des camps de jour a diminué du
tiers cette année et un camp de jour sur
cinq a fermé ses portes
on a pour cent vingt mille dollars de
remboursements donc ça c'est tous des
parents qu'on a des inscrits qui étaient
déjà inscrits la confusion nette à 450
de capacités plan net à 175 maximum pour
cette mère de famille co propriétaire
d'une boutique à montréal l'offre des
comptes jour n'est pas adapté aux
travailleurs elle pourrait freiner la
relance économique
tous nos enfants vont finir le camp au
plus tard à 4 heures et ça c'est
vraiment un problème pour nous parce que
notre pays est ouvert jusqu'à 6 heures
des fois jusqu'à 8 heures les jeudis et
les vendredis
donc pour l'instant on est ouvert à
temps partiel on n'est pas capable
d'ouvrir à temps plein on peut pas
demander à un animateur ou une
animatrice d'un service de 7 heures le
matin à 6 heures le soir parce qu'on
veut respecter concède la bulle on veut
quand on veut que les enfants soient en
contact avec un ou deux animateurs si le
déconfinement se poursuit l'offre en
camps pourraient évoluer ajoute
l'association des camps du québec
d'ailleurs elle note que certains camps
n'affiche pas complet
québec accorde 11 millions de dollars
aux camps de jour accrédités pour les
aider à traverser la crise
un été différent que les animateurs
espèrent mémorable c'est qu'au final
enfin et fatalement c'est a tellement
cool cet été aucun c'est seul but
puis je pense dans voyages mais quand
même ici marie josée pas capcom ou radio
canada montréal